created by Jack Kirby and Stan Lee in
1963 the x-men issue for Wanda Maximoff
the Scala which has some of the
strangest stories in comics from her
mechanical ex-husband to the many many
read cons of her father as here are
things Marvel wants you to forget about
The Scarlet Witch what even is Chaos
magic scholar which started out as a
mutant who had hex powers which
basically meant that she could do
anything that the writer wanted beyond
wearing all red Wanda Maximoff wasn't
really much of a Scarlet Witch at all
she wasn't even Scarlett on her first
cover appearance she wasn't truly which
she until writers Steve Englehart had a
study magic under Agatha Harkness an
actual witch in 1974 see Avengers issue
128 later stories would establish that
she was gifted at magic because Kath on
the Marvel Universe equivalent to
Cthulhu molded her a birth to be the
perfect vessel for his physical form add
in later retcons involving chaos magic
and reality warping and her powers have
remained as ambiguous today as they were
when she first appeared her thing is
neuroelectric interfacing telekinesis
mental manipulation he's fast and she's
weird who's your daddy
well wander and her brother Pietro were
popularly known as the children of
magneto that hasn't always been the case
in 1974 giant sized Avengers issue one
it's established that they were the
children of the Whizzer and Miss America
superheroes from Marvel's Golden Age
Wonder learns that years later the
Whizzer had brought his pregnant wife to
wondercore Mountain where she died after
delivering twins notably this delivery
occurred in the watchful eye of the High
Evolutionary a geneticist obsessed with
as his name suggests evolution bova a
talking Cal woman delivered Wanda and
Pietro because comics are weird this
would be reckoned in 1979 The Avengers
issue 185 in this version a pregnant
woman named Magna appears at wundagore
mountain to the liver twins Pietro and
Wonder
after she disappears the High
Evolutionary gives him away to a
traveling Romani family the maximov's
who raised them until Wanda and Pietro
join magneto shortly before x-men issue
four then brought to our home by a
little light
[Music]
seriously who's your daddy magnesia was
officially confirmed to be their father
at 1983 sir vision and Scarlet Witch
issue for finally answering the
lingering question of who wonders
biological father was but that wasn't
the end of it we are not your natural
parents what are you saying
in 2014's access one that discovered
that magnesia wasn't actually her father
later she discovered that she and Pietro
weren't actually ever mutants at all but
regular humans had been experimented on
by High Evolutionary at birth to create
super-powered siblings in this most
recent retcon wonders biological family
is currently settled to be the Maximoff
coincidentally that revelation happened
right around the time that 20th Century
Fox had established that they owned the
film rights to both Magneto and mutants
as a concept but there's probably no
connection demon babies for a while
wonder was Merritt a synthezoid Avenger
vision they even managed to have twins
together through Wanda's magic
unfortunately it turned out that while
the children technically existed they
only existed while Wanda was actively
thinking of them that a monic villain
master pandemonium stolen absorbed the
twins giving him the unintentionally
hilarious visual of a man with babies
for arms it later turned out that the
babies were pieces of the demonic
Mephisto soul that have been blasted off
and Wonder one two children she
unintentionally siphoned off parts of
Mephisto broken Souls to create them
Agatha Harkness was able to banish
Mephisto by erasing Wanda's memory of
ever having children which thanks to her
subconscious reality-warping abilities
meant that they stopped existing from
them solved right Avengers disassembled
in The Avengers disassembled story arc
Scarlet Witch hits a breaking point
after the wasp accidentally reminds her
of her memory wipes children a psychotic
break that follows features are going on
an incredibly violent rampage against
the Avengers Hawkeye doesn't survive
vision is ripped in half
Agatha Harkness is discovered as a
rotting corpse and Scarlet Witch herself
gets put into the custody of Magneto
until she can get the help she needs
which is a whole lot of help
House of M wonders reality-warping
powers a mental break led to the 2005
marvel crossover event House of M in
which wonder was coerced into rewriting
reality so that mutants are the dominant
life-form on the planet when confronted
by the various heroes who remembered the
old world wonder response a distressing
kill by writing the mutant genome
turning almost every mutant in the world
into a powerless human smoke about
lashing our brotherly love in the
alternate reality of The Ultimates comic
series Scarlet Witch and quicksilver's
codependent relationship was rewritten
to be almost explicitly romantic between
the twins worse in Ultimates 3 the wasp
even chides Captain America for
expressing his judgement of their
romance by telling him that his world
war 2 sense of morality is outdated in
this modern world gross two Avengers
infinity war and Beyond with all the
storylines mentioned above you might be
thinking of a Marvel Cinematic Universe
made the right decision to simplify both
our origin and our superpowers Escala
which not bound by constant family
revelations and the codependent brother
has a lot of story potential still we'll
have to see how that changes as Disney
starts to incorporate 20th Century Fox
concepts with the planned merger
whether that means leaning into the
magical angle like Doctor Strange or we
incorporating our into the mutant world
just about anything can happen you can
control your fear
[Music]
well almost it is probably fair to
assume that we won't be seeing over the
provide Midwife or master pandemonium
and his baby arms on the big screen
anytime soon thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]